I have a g-wagen dude don't ever get
that [ __ ] twisted okay I want I want
to be serious I know we have a [ __ ]
fun podcast here and it's a it's on the
comedy charts yeah dude I have a G Wagen
okay I don't I don't ever want you to
get that [ __ ] twisted and that's
[ __ ] serious dude yeah okay all right
yeah I don't know dr. fun okay well I'm
not all right
I don't need to be I don't need to
quantify what you drive oh oh hey no no
it's all good dude
let's go back to fun huh let's go back
you know you're talking to me the way I
talk to that door guy I'm saying are you
laughing in a good way or what sly you
see what happens is mmm blood starts to
boil yeah
blood starts to boil right and I'm
starting to see the bun I see it and I
don't want to make [ __ ] I don't want
make your body look like your bank
account which is one low dance okay okay
Brian full ode dance Cal don't start
these because I could do my shows and
people go full of dead yeah maybe we'll
call me sweet tart tart nasty do you
know how many guys come on go ahead just
say this you're a sweet tart tart mess
and they run away I'm like okay the gay
out of a big gay al what's that you said
he called me gay al I told me okay Oh
ice and old or something and with
wrinkles or something I don't I forget
but even at the show when I rep why I
say and then my friend he said that
Barry go and then my partner in crime
Brian the kid count walks in guys would
yell big guy he is a 51 year old gay men
they love is doesn't have fans but you
know when they turn against you man and
they are turning against you oh dense
Brian this full oh that's Kali
good good oh my god no shirt sell them
by the way man
oh real well man cuz they're [ __ ] fly
dude they're fun they're funny [ __ ] and
they're fly dude leading how that's like
you got yeah
bro you're damn right yeah okay they're
bleeding bro yeah whatever kind of
[ __ ] buy is such a [ __ ] you're such
a that's what I do when I [ __ ] go to
the bank how's it sign that's what I do
I don't give a [ __ ] dude I don't give a
[ __ ] you're the most disrespectful man
I'm respectful cuz I'm being the way I
wanna be good and I me true me is being
respectful cuz you get the true me you
Welk and also I'm [ __ ] I'm relaxed in
front of you man because we have a
rapport we're good dude if I'm
uncomfortable I'm not being the real me
that's disrespectfully [ __ ] bro right um
I'm chilling I'm chilling yeah and [ __ ]
the guest of the year dude I don't want
I don't want to be the guest we didn't
bring it I'm my own [ __ ] you listen to
congratulations if you wanna [ __ ]
dose of me dude
hey if you wanna the posts come over -
congratulations do it hey listen I want
to be a guest I'm great come on watch
it's not making a Pakistan on duty they
[ __ ] are you still working out like
crazy yeah dude are you though you don't
post as much yeah because I'm on the
road but I do all I'm not no I'm not
dude you're next looks don't take this
the wrong way what your neck looks oh no
your eyes boy your neck looks us
unfortified I know
dude let's say you know bro I'm [ __ ]
anything for your legs ever and we know
that by SWAT and that's okay I squat I
squat every [ __ ] 3-4 days not just
the bar do you squat because your legs I
can do 225 5 times probably not true
right dude I've worked very hard will
you have new knees and we know that your
new eyes well your your new knees have
never been used so I can see how you
would bear someway what are you talking
about I have a new knee we've never done
anything with your legs dude
besides sit and stand ups no no no no no
I [ __ ] and impose I like going to the
gym I work out very hard I sweat very
hard and
[ __ ] and I burned calories man I do
an 80s workout you do lat pull-downs and
you don't do that bench press on the and
then you walk and go home oh you know
what [ __ ] I meant detect you and give me
some heat yeah duh that company rogue
for the salt bikes yeah you trying to
get one no I want I want the treadmill
that we ran out on it though the curved
one that's the skill mill you want a
would way there's seven million there
seven thousand dollars there's seven
million dollar lien mister seven million
dollars so there's seven number I walked
up one and I was like oh that's too
expensive I can't treadmill might be
able to help you with that really I'm
not
what are you doing hey hey hey hey
Brendan why are you doing a lot of
fighter in the kid dude I'm being
respectful don't do don't do that why
wouldn't I give that to you as it's a
gift it's a gift it's a gift